los misiles recorrieron 1500 km antes de
alcanzar su objetivo es lo que afirma la
agencia de prensa oficial del régimen
norcoreano en un comunicado presume de
la excelencia de su sistema de armamento
y celebra estar en posesión de una nueva
arma de disuasión destinada a combatir
las maniobras militares de fuerzas
hostiles para corea del norte estos
misiles de crucero de largo alcance son
un avance tecnológico los especialistas
temen un nuevo tipo de arma capaz de
llegar a corea del sur ya japón pasando
inadvertida por los radares de defensa
antimisiles sí sí es verdad que
dispararon un misil de un alcance de
1.500 km esto supone una amenaza para la
paz y la seguridad de japón y de la
región estamos muy preocupados hoy
distrito polo de áreas
numerosas resoluciones del consejo de
seguridad de naciones unidas prohíben a
corea del norte continuar con sus
programas de armamento sin embargo a
pesar de múltiples sanciones
internacionales los ensayos han seguido
en los últimos años
lyon yann ha realizado con éxito pruebas
de misiles balísticos capaces de llegar
a estados
las conversaciones sobre el tema nuclear
están en punto muerto desde el fracaso
de la cumbre de hanoi en febrero de 2019
entre kim jong-un y donald trump el
presidente joe biden espera reanudar el
diálogo con las autoridades norcoreanas
y se declara dispuesto a reunirse con
ella